this is a survey that we've been
conducting for a number of years and we
are huge mortgage originators in the UK
we have a fifty billion pound plus
mortgage business and it was clear to us
that there was a lot going on behind the
scenes with mum and dad so we we
therefore have a survey every year of
about a thousand families right across
the UK to see what's happening and it
revealed this amazing evidence that the
bank of mum and dad was creeping up into
being a really significant player in the
mortgage market here in the UK you
surprised at some of the regional
discrepancies for example the southwest
of England thirty thousand pounds on
average from mum and dad now I think
there will be regional damage and so I
think the similarity is it is it is
absolutely the most common theme that
actually right across the UK banker mum
and dad is typically helping to the tune
of twenty to thirty thousand pounds to
help children really with their deposit
on their house you think this is an
equivalent sense that it helps people
get onto the housing ladder it's a good
thing that it helps parents help their
children which is a good good thing to
do it's a product of thirty years of
policy failure in the housing market and
that's the the problem is and we haven't
really got any concrete solutions at the
moment and therefore we need to resolve
the housing supply problem instead of
cheering running when house prices for
inflation is five percent or seven
percent or ten percent
we should recognize that that's not a
good thing for the economy and we're all
beginning to recognize that actually
it's terrible for the the younger
generations both if they're renting or
if they're buying so decline in house
prices would be a good thing that well a
steadying of the house price increase so
that they I don't think declining
deflation is really a good thing and
therefore very modest price increases
would be much more in line with wages
and the inflation of other products so
it's seen as a normal product rather
than this obsession that we've all had
for the last thirty years about talking
about how much house prices have gone up
and my generation got free housing free
education and great pension schemes
sadly this generation is not getting any
of the above and therefore we've had
these windfall gains we should be
sharing them with the younger people
that's the consequence it's an
unintended consequence of
of Housing Policy so you're clearly very
concerned about intergenerational
inequality should the government
dispense with the triple lock on state
pensions then well I think that's an
issue that they need to really address
because that helped bring a lot of
pensioners out of poverty and I think
that's one of the successes in recent
years but there's a desperate
intergenerational unfairness but in both
sides of the housing market I think the
housing is too expensive for the young
people and there isn't sufficient supply
of relevant and useful housing for elder
people in the Britain only 1% of all
housing new-build housing in the UK is
built especially for elderly people on
or retiring people so we need to change
both ends of the housing market but this
isn't going to change overnight even
with you and others investing as much as
you are know it's a long-term strategy
and we've always had short-term
solutions from the government and those
30 years of short-term solutions
resulted in a terrible consequence of
that we massively under built now for 30
years and house prices are way too high
we've got to have a an adjustment
mechanism otherwise the bank of mum and
dad will become an even bigger bank next
year